it's probably not going to be my
permanent home I've still got my my
place on Twitter I'm still going to be
using that I think as the main form of
communication but we can't Overlook the
fact that the biggest tech company in
the world essentially has waded into
this new space and said actually we
think we can do it better if Twitter was
a sinking ship and we've had lots of
small lifeboats kind of being launched
off it you can name them Mastodon Blue
Sky T2 social spoutable I could go on
probably for another half out with all
of those this is kind of like the the
well-equipped military frigate with
massive guns on the bow that is saying
actually we're here to save you hop on
board we'll take you to safety oh I love
your Naval analogy there
um is it gonna work what's your instinct
telling you I think
um it stands a better chance than most
we do have to kind of delve back into
history here this isn't the first time
that meta formerly known as Facebook has
seen the success of a competitor
realized that it could threaten it and
has decided to try and make its own
version of it
um we've seen this with Tick Tock we've
seen this with Snapchat we've seen this
with multiple other platforms and
formats
um they've previously not had huge
success Instagram reels which is their
Tick Tock alike has done okay probably
the best of all of those copycats but
still not brilliant
um the thing that I think is different
here is that the incumbent is in such a
weak position we've never had someone
seemingly almost intentionally wrecking
an app from the inside out in the same
way that we have Elon Musk and Twitter
and so I think it stands a good chance
um the one thing that weighs against it
ironically is
that is matter doing this um for all
that the the kind of billions that it
can throw at this if it chose to will
benefit it there's also this kind of
uncool cultural cachet that comes with
being the parent company of Facebook
we've lived through Cambridge analytica
we also are just kind of Highly
suspicious I think of this company and
what it does and so even beyond that
Facebook is kind of seen as a a tragic
place where you know old people only
exist nowadays rather than the cool
happening place that it needs to be in
order to succeed yeah it's interesting
that you see
in terms of its billions of followers
before we get on to that who is threads
aimed at specifically is it Twitter
users who are unhappy with the recent
changes or is it a bigger audience
I think it's
um and it's core those disaffected
Twitter users but I think that it's
trying to broaden it out a lot
um
one of the things historically that has
um you know sort of played against
Twitter has been while it's core user
base are the decision makers politicians
journalists
um people in power who can dictate and
kind of sway public discussion
um it hasn't had a comparison to other
apps much of a big user base we're
talking sort of you know a quarter of a
billion 300 million odd people which
sounds a lot when you think about it but
actually you know the meta family of
apps which includes Facebook Instagram
and WhatsApp has three billion so you
know huge amounts more
um I think that meta is trying to make
threads more palatable to those kind of
you know 2.7 billion people who use
their apps but don't use Twitter's apps
by making it you know as friction free
as possible to sign up so you need an
Instagram account that's the first thing
to say
um but lots of us have that but then you
just basically press a button and it
ports over your account your username
your followers suggests who you can
follow there which makes it really
really easy and I think that possibly
they're trying to bring in more people
to that tent and get them what we used
to call back when Twitter was launched
microblogging it's really interesting
thing is that I have an Instagram
account and a Twitter account and they I
find they are very very different
audiences and I use them for very
different things
do you think that as you I mean you
touch not already but do you think that
meta is trying to capitalize on on
Twitter's recent troubles here and hope
that they can somehow end up turning out
a product that is something people are
looking for look you don't spin up an
app like threads overnight it would be
um silly to say
that Mark Zuckerberg has managed to
develop this huge thing in a matter of
days it's obviously been going on for
months but I think that the the timing
of the release of threads is not
coincidental over the last week or so
Elon Musk has made some pretty huge
unforced errors around Twitter that have
hugely alienated
um the user base of or what remains of
it because it's been kind of eroded uh
multiple times by his decisions over the
last nine months this past weekend he
made kind of three pretty catastrophic
ones number one uh essentially saying
um that anybody who didn't have a
Twitter account could no longer look at
Twitter content a decision he's since
overturned but basically managed to
build a wall around a company that is
solely dependent on people being able to
look in then he decided to limit for
those who do have accounts the number of
posts that they can see every single day
which is also bizarre because Twitter
relies mostly on Advertising revenue and
advertisers want to know that they have
a an Engaged user base on that app and
if you uh basically say to people right
you've had a thousand views of posts you
now can no longer look at anymore go
home find somewhere else that's shooting
yourself underfoot and then he alienated
the hardcore Twitter to users
um who use a tool called tweetdeck which
is essentially a different way of
looking at the app which allows you to
consume much more information much more
quickly by saying that he's going to put
that behind a paywall in a month so
those three things I think have
contributed to threads being released
now I think probably it's expedited
um the the kind of publication and
announcement of this but I don't think
that this is an immediate sort of
knee-jerk reaction to Elon Musk ruining
Twitter this past week it's more a
recognition that this has been the the
direction of travel for a long long time
and trying to take advantage of that